I think we start today we look at a
couple experiments we play with the
renderer some and then we'll do uh some
other
one it's very close but it's not quite
there it looks like
149 yeah this pillar here 14 49 is the
best I've figured
out
38 I'm curious to see
um yeah what this thing found
200 filter system drives me nuts that it
doesn't work
okay Neptune you guys really got to fix
that your query thing is just really
glitchy
here very low value of
this interesting
burito front here
is 861 at 138 is the
then to go look at
the what's it sweet
progress One update
Epoch mostly 5 12ms
EPO yeah so it's just not um I think it
is the hyper Fram tuner just like having
a very bit a small bit of drift
around stuff like
this but we did confirm what we want
wanted to
anyways BR a few if you want to try
about rendering awesome yeah I was just
going over morning experiments and then
I was going to keep working on the
rendering
anyways let check a couple of experiment
and get
some wake myself up
this one looks actually pretty damn
similar to
um to the previous curve so the question
I guess is
let go find my
favorite go pick your favorite run
there's a lot of good
runs we'll do this one
though 23336
it's got three update EPO instead of two
though I
think yeah so this it does not need this
normalization which is weird
I do think that that is going to screw
it up eventually but for
now maybe it's okay
I don't think it screws up the value
function learning honestly maybe it
screws up Advantage but Advantage does
subtract mean so actually I think it
could be
fine could be
fine well there's work to do on this
we'll probably Circle back to this later
in the day
I'm going to send a quick message on the
side
here actually I just got to check one
email and then we will get to cool
rendering
alarm it's mountain time two hours
behind I think it
rendering Captain they'll be here in a
second I'm sure
I think these are multiplied by the
render scale or something
right yeah these have to be
see these are still going to be
too too big
I can do capital for
now oh wait no here it is
ex start pause end
transform uh okay I need to see how this
was in the
I don't understand how this thing works
here
he fixing some AIO
settings you explain how this guideline
drawing is supposed to work so I can fix
it um yeah that's one of the more
complicated parts so like it needs a
rotation on it right yeah
um I was going to make it it just a
cylinder instead of a line it's
now you can try but I honestly don't
think a cylinder will look as good
honestly think it'll look kind of
wonky well what would you use probably
just 2D still I think if you look at the
original game it's just 2D with maybe
some like little Shader to make like it
looks like a laser under like that's
under smoke or something I don't know
well what I was going to do
is I was going to make it so so yeah
you're right right like it might be
weird to play in a certain perspective
but uh it can be really cool to render I
mean you could even this is like an end
where you could even do one of these
here like congratulations you're a big
lab
now you want to absolutely Merk Deep
Mind with uh this awesome m
Capture the Flag yeah I've seen that all
right these right but
then where's their Universe of
things well they got artwork done for it
but
right wake playing oh it's yeah it's
based on
Quake but like you see how they
have like all these uh all these Ms just
like tiled like this mhm I was thinking
H maybe uh maybe we could do
something oh you have multiple ends
running simultaneously
mhm you could do
that I actually did at one point I
hooked up um like the neural MMO
renderer uh at one point in one of the
earlier prototypes I had it so that you
could render screenshots of like
different M's of different sizes tiled
together
H yeah I don't think it'd be too bad to
do this because not hard at all the way
I have it set up now you can you can
render multiple M simultaneously with
different Windows though not in the same
window but I don't think it'
be I don't know
it'd be very easy yeah it wouldn't be
hard be very
easy um but um the other thing I was
yeah the other thing I was thinking
about is just like for spectating either
uh first person like free cam or fixed
ISO uh first person I honestly think
would be kind of nauseating for this
game no no no first person like overview
like up
top though I have always wondered cuz
like it's so easy to just fit with the
camera I've always wondered what some
games would look like if you just change
the perspective right like what would
League of Legends look like as a first-
person
game I you'd lose a lot of detail
wouldn't you because you can't oh yeah
you absolutely would it would be a
totally different game
right but like the same is true of other
like okay what would OverWatch look like
if it were a third person like aess
third person stick
shooter yeah um
I guess you kind of get a sense of that
when you're watching kill cams because
you see them in third
person right uh the OverWatch ones are
still first person oh I'm thinking of a
different game then I don't know I don't
really play many
shooters anyways um yeah I'm not I'm not
saying it must be ISO or anything I just
figured I'd like try some stuff let's
fix this at least I do think we want to
keep it in 3D and then like for now and
then Chuck shaders on and we might still
do screen space stuff like cuz some of
the UI stuff is is tricky um yeah like I
I think um a lot well I saw you kept the
text on the sides 2D which is I think is
smart because that's purely purely UI
and I also think the text um like the
ammo text should be kept
2D yeah I hav I haven't done anything
with that yet okay I think that's
probably going to be good as well 2D
yeah I think the charge meter for
certain weapons one small I think that
should also stay 2D one small change I
might make to make it a little sleeker
though I noticed in the original it kind
of Curves around the Drone to make it a
little cleaner looking and it's a little
more out it's a little less blocky it's
a little more sleeker but that'd be easy
to do you just you just make it uh yeah
you can just do that with the draw ring
call um it's not hard you probably can I
just haven't figured I haven't done any
of that stuff yet cuz now I have to
figure out a different
transform um there's a separate
transform to do but no big deal well at
least I already have 2D transforms
figured out well I guess the original
camera yeah I guess it's different now
that's annoying no big deal do can you
explain how you did this like there was
rotation or something here for the aim
guide I don't see where it
is uh I can you turn line numbers on
again because it's it's hard to pinpoint
I just have to keep telling you higher
or
lower it no
yeah so it should be an
822 um yeah again some of a lot of this
like like a trig math stuff I got help
from an LM and it just like so I don't
really totally understand how it works
because my tree is very Rusty but you
rotation Matrix works right kind of yeah
yeah
2D examples are really
easy oh and there's uh there's your
camera production
matrices but I should here's your I mean
yeah here your here's your 3D rotation
Matrix and it's literally just uh one so
identity on the axis you don't care
about and then on the the plane you are
rotating cosine negative s s cosine
which is the 2D rotation Matrix and you
can kind of convince yourself right you
can see
90° right this would flip
90° X or was it negative YX MH right
negative y uh negative x negative Y and
then you have to cosga sign sign cosine
is the uh arbitrary angle
rotation so wait why are there four
numbers in there I get like one like
yeah why is why is it a matrix I
guess multiply it by
so you multip this by XY so your X Y is
Vector says how so for the new x
coordinate right the new x coordinate is
going to be uh cosine of the old x
coordinate minus s of the old
y-coordinate and then was it the new
y-coordinate is going to be S of the
xord old x coordinate plus cosine of the
old y coordinate oh I see gotcha and if
you actually get some pen and paper and
you draw out where that actually lies up
we'll see that that is a rotation Matrix
yeah like this literally this
diagram okay cool makes sense so that's
how that works and then if you want to
make a big fancy 3D rotation Matrix um
you can multiply them all together so
like if you want to rotate around three
different axes and you see like a really
fancy formula this is just the rotation
Matrix
for a plane where's it yeah Elementary
rotation matrices the
ones um and you can if you want to apply
multiple you don't have to apply one
then the next then the next you can
multiply them all together right in
order to do all the transform at once
yeah but then there's this weird thing
called gimbal lock and then Quan get in
and that's where I stopped knowing how
things work but in the meantime yeah
heard of conans or whatever but
um yeah whatever like I said this is
anything like impulse Wars is my first
time doing Graphics programming in my
whole life so not great at
it yeah I've always I've never really
written anything with any sort of front
end whatsoever whe whether it be a web
front end or some kind of graphical
front end web front end is kind of
cancer I've used so many different
things I've done for neural mam Mo alone
I did 3js pandas P game
Ki
Unity what Ty did viously the most
recent ones in
rayb um there was like this jck
typescript client there's so much stuff
I've like written half dozen different
clients for just Nur Mo yeah I've I've
always focused on uh like backend stuff
or like client inter like you know tues
if anything so how come you don't answer
your email did I miss
something did you send me something that
I
missed what email did you
use
meantime
um oh so I think I missed
anything okay um about what you did so
far though
I think it it's looking pretty good
overall but I'm not sure I'm a fan of
the puffer colors on this mend though to
be honest like at least replacing the
background to be the Scion and the blue
walls with the Scion like the there's
less contrast between the other stuff
with the cyan and the yellow it's not
final I was just slotting stuff in to
try I want to actually get the like the
random animations in first let me see
what let me see what this apparently I
got sent something for T
email actually I think was there an
issue with that
lately
email somebody said that they sent me
something and asked me why I don't
answer my email and the the usual reason
is that I didn't see it or didn't get it
um don't I'm not showing on
stream I have it on the side monitor but
I can't
find let me just send myself something
from my MIT email real
quick so I make sure because I thought I
thought I had something weird with
that no I get it
okay when did you send this
I'm not seeing anything that doesn't
look like an ad so
far
so usually the reason is if I'm not
answering something I haven't gotten it
or haven't seen
it
0227 oh
okay hang on let me just make sure I
haven't missed for
problem I try to answer stuff generally
and not miss things so
I really need to clean up my MIT mail
cuz my puffer box is pretty clean but
like just from MIT and stuff I've just
gotten so much crap in this
inbox honestly I should literally just
like make one of the filters where you
just get rid of everything that has
unsubscribe
button oh I didn't even know exist
that's
here I literally only have spam from
that day
for well I usually do answer MIT as well
but yeah jarz at puffer
doai but I like yeah I don't see I even
looking back at the MIT inbox now I
don't see anything in
here like it's not I don't get that that
much spam they're only like 10 things
from that day and I don't see anything
here
I'm like I'm pretty easy to get a hold
of like instantly by the way right like
I you can get a hold of me here on
stream on freaking Discord on X like I'm
very easy to get a hold of I don't
generally just ignore stuff unless
people are straight up
trolling don't don't ask me to launch a
freaking token and it'll be
so this just computes an angle right
then how you do how did you make it so
that this is a
rectangle where the width
is I don't see a rotate on this anywhere
was there
one um yeah so in the draw rectangle Pro
you can draw at an
angle
oh I see so most of the time I got away
with doing that only one or two times
does RB not let you um just tell it what
angle to draw it at so I only had to the
angles the trails and stuff
but most of the time I could just say
hey rotate this for me and it just did
so that was nice yeah cylinder doesn't
have a rotate on it
sadly
yeah so I mean it's
just so wait it looks like protein is
really resistant to filling out the
right
end of the distribution do I set High
men link me sweep Spencer
it's not resistant to it um it's
resistant to wasting time filling out
the right end if it can't find
anything I just literally the other day
had a sweep where it would only fill out
at the top end because uh it was like
because the highest cost kept finding
better
solution and actually the opposite
problem is the one that's way more
common and harder to
fix oh it only does expensive stuff and
not yeah whoa it waste too much time is
the way more common thing that's hard to
fix but I think we kind of did
it you just linked me your
entire your entire uh runs so I assume
it's this
one and do you have a
dashboard uh oh you do
hell there's some like there's some uh
distribution thing going on here
where I mean you don't have all the
parameters it might be update EPO or
something you can see it's kind of
split right there're all these ones that
just get stuck on score of point4 and
then there a few that do
better so this is weird because it's not
able to find it's not able to replicate
this
point right the thing that's happening
here is that it found a good point up
here and it's not able to replicate it
consistently so um it's it's building a
predictive model right of like what
hyper parameters m to what scores and
it's trying to beat the best score and I
don't think it can right now because
there's something like this is not the
way a curve should look there is
something wrong most likely in the
environment um there shouldn't be like a
shelf here but then also some points
that just do way
better you can see there's like a flat
hard line and it's at
0.4 so presumably there is something
there as well
you can actually see it in the graph
right some of these runs blow right by
0.4 and some of them get hard stuck at
it so yeah there's definitely something
different in the end
that looking forward I think I got the
email
you and it's not in spam
either are you spelling my name wrong or
something
it's j s u a r easy at puffer
doai you could always send the email and
chat right nice charts thank you yeah
it's just kind of odd um
we we need to figure this rotation thing
out for like several different different
things I think
um but but um box 2D should have that
right isn't there like a B2 rot or
something
yeah what what do you need to do you
need to rotate something yeah I I get it
above I get it at um
oh yeah here it is so get
angle is there like um can we just like
rotate in box 2D yeah well I mean you
can transform it using our rotational
Matrix I mean you can you can tell it to
rotate an object but that'll like you
know change its physical
body can it do like
um aim
back
to what it aim guide width
is aim guide width is how long the aim
guide
is how long it is
yeah this one was kind of tricky to get
right honestly but yeah just so why do
you think it like are you just trying
out a cylinder to see how it looks I'm
not sure like what it's also it's just
like the thing is in 3D now so if I just
brought I can't just draw it in the only
way you can just purely draw it in 2D I
think is if it's it's full top de down
but even then if you're going to use a
perspective camera like with Parallax it
still looks weird doesn't it I don't
know I I I need to boot up uh retrograde
Arena again and see I I bet they have
some effects on the guide it it might be
3D but it looks more just like a because
you don't think we will we will be able
to put effects on the things as well
yeah but I'm just wondering like how
they made it look the way they did
because I don't know anything about M
Graphics I would be really surprised if
they had had 2D models in a perspective
game that's kind of weird okay yeah yeah
I don't know
um oh did you see what I linked
yesterday in in development that other
like companion library to
you know what I bet
happened uh I bet that this I bet that
this got um put into my this probably
went into my spam because it's that
because that's not my name the original
methods listed as
Jonathan so that's that's probably what
happened wait what why is it listed as
Jonathan no in the in the email that he
sent me the original email had my name
wrong so it probably went into spam oh
because yeah yeah yeah right because
like they get your if they get your name
wrong it's like
uh it's like a common thing that they'll
just put like a common name on a Spam
message
yeah so I do answer my email if uh I do
not like check my SPAM box consistently
but I don't even see it there though I
think it just like but it just gets rid
of anything that's too old in spam so I
can't even see it all right yeah I will
uh I will reply to set something up for
this week of March
funny that's totally what
happened
um I think that if you're looking for
just like General graphic stuff right I
think that this is what you'd want to do
you'd want to
do make
rotation is there a B2
rotate uh no there's just like the B2
raw and you can do stuff on that
okay well we could just get we could
literally just do
um what is it
E2 is it or
uh Vector
three
yes so yeah Joseph did you see what I
posted in development
yesterday oh let me see um I just found
it's so I joined the uh RB Discord um
just because I figured the particle
system yeah so I it has a lot of nice
things little susp looks this is not
official right this is like it's not but
it looks really nice like if you just
look at the header include uh whatever
everything looks like very similar to um
rayb to use they have a lot of
examples I'm surprised there isn't like
I think there are a few different
projects like
this this one seems really nice though
you're going to not like it though
because it pretty much I mean you could
hack around it but like out of the box
it only works with cake because it uses
like it embeds certain stuff in you're
buying I don't know it works out of the
box like I could probably get it running
in like two minutes with my cmake thing
but it probably take a minute to get
working in like
proper but I mean they have
like yeah got decent looking stuff
loaded I'm confused like why like ra
does have 3D so what is
this yeah read it it has just a bunch of
stuff like add it on or maybe it makes
it easier I don't know I'm not really
sure honestly this material stuff I
think would be a it's just a Shader
wrapper isn't it I'm not sure I think
Raab has a material system but it it
madees it sound like it handles some
material stuff for you and it has lights
but I think it's just a lot of it's
adding on
toing yeah it's making some of it easier
to use I think I don't know but like
particles for example you can do
particles in ra but they already have a
system here you don't have to like roll
your
ownin what is
this just go to the include and just
look at what they have or look at some
of the
examples very long
file but it's comined pretty
well it has apparently better support
for deferred rendering which can be like
a huge per I don't know if we need it
but like I don't know I was reading a
little bit because that was new to me be
a big perf optimization if you're doing
a lot of lighting stuff I don't know oh
it can also render at an internal
resolution that's different so you can
do some cool stuff with that I don't
know it has a lot of cool advanced
stuff like if we're really wanted to get
into this I think this might be a nice
addition
and at least in my project be very easy
to play with because I could add it in
two seconds because it's it support
you know this is a rapper around a
rapper
right I think it does add some new
stuff well a lot of this [ __ ] here right
like this is just [ __ ] okay like all
this stuff all this is doing so the only
reason that they would have Getters and
Setters here there are two reasons one
is that they're just dumb um CU these
are just this is horrible design but the
second reason which is more valid is
that they need to set a Shader
value right and they don't want the user
to be exposed to the shaders but shaders
aren't that scary you can just expose
the shaders so like if anything I would
want like I do want a good Shader right
a lot of this stuff is just
Shader um actually we can even probably
go find it we can just like go find
their Shader here the particle system
will probably be a little different if
anything that's what I would want to
look at
but here let me let me show you
shaders they have their shaders
somewhere they inline them or something
Bloom did people put
um here they are yeah there you go
so you see all this stuff all these
shaders yeah mhm so like this is what a
bloom Shader looks like it's tiny
right
and you can just set these values right
like you can just Shader set value or
whatever you can just set these
values
um the big one is honestly just like
your general lighting
Shader yeah this is a big Shader
so this you want right this is a general
lighting
Shader and you want to make sure that
you get a good one so this one has
Shadows okay so there like all the
shadow code this is it right
here yeah it has good Shadow support
yeah um so this is
shadows and what
else veto diffuse lighting specular
so I like I don't even know if this is
the one we want but we want a Shader for
this and the shade it's just like this
is your general lighting Shadows
everything um but like you don't need a
big API over this you literally just set
these values and then the Shader runs
MH so we will look at this I I don't
want to just like grab this thing
blindly though right
you know rib is a uh rib is a GL rib is
essentially an open GL
rapper yeah right and now we have a Raab
rapper yeah yeah um I mean I I do want I
do here I want some of these features
the question will just be how we grab
them
if you want to pport this library and
make it your own just because you don't
like the Setters and Getters you can be
my guess but I would rather spend my
time just even if I don't like the API
as much I don't want to spend not it's I
don't want to grab this entire massive
Library when you need like 300
lines I mean sure you literally can grab
their Shader and then just like set
Shader and it does the same
thing if you only want the Whiting yeah
yeah but if we're doing some other stuff
you might as well just use the whole
thing cuz we're not like we're not on a
we're not on an embedded system or
something where like every you know bite
in the binary counts or we're not like
you know starved for FPS or whatever
like we we it's not like we're
struggling to maintain like 60 FPS or
something so so this is a wrapper for
the material system that ra already
has deferred
lighting directional spot I thought that
ra had maybe ra only has Point
lights I be confused but I think that's
what we need anyways we do Shadows are
cool we probably just need Omni an
omnidirectional light right just at the
top I don't know the point light that's
a point
light oh okay the which ra already has
like Spencer thing that's all it's
using oh I guess omnidirectional would
just be in every direction not yeah it
would be a point light okay
Sky yeah but if they have we don't need
a Sky Box we just need black or
something postprocessing okay some of
these are cool but these are literally
individual shaders mhm instance
rendering uh I don't think we need this
I'm not sure what that is to be I'm not
sure what instance rendering is like if
you have 50,000 of the same object and
you need them to be
bashed okay well so between begin draw
and end draw I was looking at into this
they're all batched anyways so I don't
know yeah this is a little separate it
yeah but um rustom I thought that this
is be surprised if uh if rib doesn't
include this but your seeing is Tiny
anyways yeah this that would be more
useful if we did like the huge MMO thing
I think it would still already
call stuff out I think so no no but it
renders whatever you render and if it's
not on screen it's still going to render
it you have to just not render it so
this is just makes it easy to test if
things are in the camera's view or not
basically is what I'm understanding uh
yeah so the way that you do that if you
had an overhead or even at a slight
angle is you just figure out the crop of
tiles to render and you just render
everything there that's even better than
this just like literally just put bounds
on your Loops
mhm yeah that makes
sense blit man agement I'm not sure what
a blit is oh
uh yeah renders at an internal
resolution so you can render it a
different size and then
scale yeah that's also that that's also
like a few lines of code in R is it yeah
huh so like a lot of these things that
you're seeing these features are just
things you can do in a few lines of code
with BR um the big stuff would be like
we'd have to look at the particle system
because that could be substantial and
then the shaders themselves but then you
just grab the shaders like yeah yeah so
you see how like when I'm looking at
something like this I like okay what
does this actually do yeah right because
there it's not free right it's not like
we're it's not free at all I've I've
trust me I've I've I know how to like uh
generally um what's the word like over
depths I don't just blindly include
stuff but the thing is I'm so ignorant
about rendering and how to use ra I
can't you know objectively say oh like
this is useful or not well this is just
going to confuse you more then right
because it's really easy to learn if
you're looking at something like rip
it's really easy because it's a really
really thin
abstraction yeah I don't know I looked
at a lot of examples and a lot of the I
don't know effects and stuff are still
kind of complex it's because it's a
Shader yeah I haven't used a Shader
before no so I mean you have two
different files right there's a Vertex
Shader which is like if you have a mesh
or whatever it's on every point a
fragment Shader that's on every
pixel and then it just it's a bashed
operation that does the same I mean you
can think of it like the clear way is
just it does the same thing to every
pixel but in practice it's like it will
take care of okay you know this uh these
pixels uh the these this triangle in
your mesh right ma to this this
point on in the Pix in pixel space so
then you're going to apply this to this
pixel and then you can do things like
you can get the angles at each verticy
and then you can use that to inform how
you will um how you will render and I
mean lighting is essentially it's just a
bunch of math with like the angles of
the like the angles of the polygons and
stuff right and and this is stuff people
have worked on in many many years but
like it's actually really really
accessible like if you were to just look
up here if you like if you were to just
look this up I took like one basic
course okay here's Fong reflection right
so this is what happens if you render
nothing this is diffuse rendering here's
reflection and this is like a few lines
of math and then it ends up being like a
100 line
Shader H and that's it no extra depths
so like you can very very easily learn
some of this stuff if it's interesting
to you
yeah I'm not sure how deep I'll go I'll
probably just I'm not sure probably just
enough to make it look interesting and
then we'll see if I'm actually have you
seen this
site uh what site Shader
toy no uh I think someone R referenced
it somewhere so like stuff like this
whoa that's cool right it's really cool
here's all the code for it 300 lines for
this whole thing
so shaders are really really powerful
and really
cool I mean here particle
experiment okay here's somebody's like
newbie particle system that they made
this is uh 79
lines right so the stuff is not I mean
the stuff is really cool but it's not
magic yeah somebody made a square wave
this demo this like Square I've seen
this
Shader interesting and shaders were in
the GPU so that's the point this is some
sort of crazy trippy
right here I'm actually going to do this
one manually because
um we need this we need the angle so
this is aim
angle add to
degrees so the math function take
degrees or co
uh ma cosine in radiance
radius and radius as
well sides and
color uh and I only did this the charged
one for some reason
here they're the same positions though
aren't they Yeah so basically the way I
handled charged is well if you look at
the original um normally it's just a
rectangle for the aim guide but then I
if I'm if it's charged to make it easier
to see um rather than having to watch
the meter like at the base of your drone
where your drone is you can you know
usually when you're charging a weapon
you're kind of keeping your eye on the
player trying to hit so then the whole
guide um there's like a
fainter
um I guess like um guide that's like a
little it it's not the height it's not
the width as the height but when you're
looking at it it's you think of it as
the width it's like a lower Alpha
underneath so in that then we do want to
do you just want the aim Vector I
believe yeah so this is just a direction
this is a this is just Vector that
you're aiming in as unit
Vector um should
be and then it has to take a length
though which I
calculate because there's a max length
of the game guide per weapon but then
you a lot of times want it shorter so
you're not it it doesn't just go through
is the height the length width like
right the width is the length the width
is the length the height is like how
thick it is where did width go
go wait are they the same
width no they're they're oh yeah they're
the same width because width is length
they're same wi okay so there's a
different thing that's hang on then in
that case then I had it right to begin
with yeah the only thing that's
different is the thickness yeah in that
case then we can can just do this the
way that I was doing
it um the alpha is the important part
because you don't want the whole thing
just thicker you just want it yeah I
don't know how that's going to work in
3D though you don't want the thing
thicker no you you don't just want the
whole thing thicker you want to be able
to see the at least the way I had it you
want to be able to see the original but
it's almost like yeah it has like
transparency yeah yeah that's fine
totally start radius and
radius the start POS and pause start
radius end radius sides and then color
perfect and then this aim guide is the
exact same
thing um aim
end and then it takes these
two sides and color let's see if we get
this
working I also miss I forgot what flag I
had at one point I had really nice Flags
where it would just give me the first
error and not spam me with a bunch of
garbage see I
always I always take note of those
warnings that you just ignore so well I
do except for the fact that like this is
in the middle of a port and it's just
warning me about unused variables from
stuff like where I've replaced part of
it and I haven't fully replaced stuff
because I want it there as a reference
still so it's funny um in go like the
basically like an unused variable is a
compile compiler and you can't just turn
that off you'd have to modify the
compiler itself so I just really yeah go
is a very opinionated language so um I
just got used to dealing with that so
yeah like even if I'm refactoring I just
comment things out whatever crazy unused
variable equals unused variable equals
compile warning pass wrong pointer type
to function is fine yeah no that's C
well no no Al well no if you
uh that should have warned you at least
I think it did warn you but you were
just ignoring all the warnings because
there's too many garbage warnings right
yeah which I don't blame you but I have
like all the warnings I can have enabled
and usually I just you know take care of
all of them that's how that's a big
reason how my code is so clean because I
don't have unused parameters I don't
have unused variables yeah well I mean I
do actually do that for if you look at a
lot of the puffer M it's just
the flags that I compiled with are
different from the ones that the that
python uses so I take care of whatever
ones that I have enabled but then like
there's stuff like w pedantic where it's
like hey please make your code worse in
order to satisfy this warning uh I
haven't found that to be the case a lot
W pedantic yeah like it finds some
annoying things but for the most part
yeah I don't know but see like all the
undf undefined behavior and stuff like I
want to I I want the warnings be ped
because I want to you know potentially
catch future bugs and stuff so I don't
mind that what's is fine if the opinions
are like not
[ __ ] I mean in my opinion or there's
been like one or two ped okay there have
been like one or two pedantic warnings
that were just invalid for what I was
doing but I specifically disabled them I
said okay give me all the pantic
warnings except like these two okay but
then also like and then with the scon
stuff that is annoying like the scon
generated code will trigger the pedantic
but in cmake you can just say yeah don't
do pedantic for this one file yeah so
cmake is
nice
sometimes um work it's great I would
love to know why this is an
unclaimed
variable what is where is T is that new
right
here tells me it's unused on the next
line oh because I forgot
a yeah that would do
it oh I'm try I'm should be hopefully
pretty close to getting the whole like
entity pulling ID thing working so I can
get the black hole weapon actually
working but that' be cool yeah um
fighting some bugs
so I'm able to reuse some of box 2D
stuff which is nice I just include their
internal headers and just use some of
their pooling code
holy why isn't why aren't the aim guys
rotating I
guess well I saw I've seen them rotate a
few times I don't know if they're
rotating
correctly yeah I
don't the aim guite or the respawn
guides are weird they just get huge they
grow get huge they go small yeah I
haven't fixed those
yet I mean it's like it's
rotating
so I think if
you I think if you look at the original
game I think the respawn guides were
2D the respawn guides were 2D yeah like
just the ring that like closes in we
could make it 2D I was just playing with
something yeah I I haven't been able I
actually haven't been able to like to
play with that nicely because for
whatever reason the 3D stuff doesn't
load in until the game starts fully yeah
I saw that I'm not sure why that's
weird I the thing is I don't intend for
it to be like this weird mesh thing I
think what's more likely is we're going
to get like a soft fading spere
somehow yeah we you can try it but I
honestly think just a 2d Circle would
look the best could be it could be
ring I mean there lot could also put the
ring in the plane of the game that could
also be
cool what do you mean it could be like
it could be like a ring so it's like it
looks like a 2d ring but it's in the
plane of the
game as opposed to in the plane of what
the
screen yeah I don't see how that's
different so it's like it would be in
perspective essentially so it's like a
ring around it like as it yeah you could
do stuff like that I think it'd make it
less obvious like I think at that point
personally like you could try it and see
but my my gut is that it would make it
less obvious well if it looks worse I'm
not going to do it but I I think you
should try a bunch of stuff I would like
to fix this so we can actually see these
things aiming at each other because it's
clearly they're not aiming at each other
right yeah because if you're trying to
play right now you have no idea where
you're aiming and until I got the aim
gues worked out it was like impossible
to play because you just kind of it's
it's a major thing
yeah the very early days it was like
okay where' that shot go so this is it's
not yeah you can clearly see it's like
not doing it I also don't know what's up
with the length of these
things yeah I mean I
have presumably it's just this thing
drone pause X drone pause Y and then you
just specify the aim end vector
right um and this just has to be the
correct math
right like if I just just to make sure
that this is
working right if I just do aim
end if we just do like this one plus
two +
five and then Z is this plus five it
should be at an angle right
so they're like still all the vectors
are all still different
right yeah so I don't think this is like
some other thing that's being drawn over
it I
think what what other thing I like I
don't even think that this is the like
what we're looking at I think if I
comment this we're still going to have
it there
no okay that was the cylinder that's
being drawn interesting
enough I did get the trails working you
saw right yeah I they're offset from the
projectile a little bit but yeah I'm
surprised they're working
projectiles yeah like if you look really
closely it's like they're hooked oh they
might in certain angles I there might be
an offset to deal with but also the uh
the player
Trails yeah the player Trails look good
the the projecti I guess it's hard to
tell because it's it's just so far we'll
like have to zoom in and stuff yeah the
explosions don't open with you fix us
right so this was
actually aim
end I'm confused here because I
literally have the AIM end Vector
specified
as why is it always refering
Z as plus five I mean what if I do this
right yeah so that
works right that's kind of cool looking
[Music]
actually but then if I do plus five it
didn't it did something really
unintuitive I
think like these should all be facing
the same direction but they're
not somehow
right
yeah so I don't see how these are all
facing different directions now do
you
uh
no oh wait pause why I have it pause y
for both
it's off a little bit but there are
actually like it like they are like you
can see the aim Vector is flipping
around to the right spot or like it's it
is flipping when it is aiming I think
there's an offset here or
something also this is too short right
yeah yeah way too
okay yeah I messed with this because um
it was in like pixel space or
something so this doubles the wi the
length of the a
guys
holy that looked really cool well I
didn't it like it just like did like
this Ricochet bounce off of everything
oh yeah that happens in that map
sometimes I think the biggest thing that
would make this look a lot cleaner well
two two things like change the
perspective to be top down and then
let's do top down for you
um I so the way the original was you
couldn't completely see through the
walls you could just see their edges
does that make sense and I was trying to
figure out how we're going to do that
maybe like we draw I got to look at it
but it might be Shader well no I think
it might be even simpler than that we
just draw like basically we draw the
wireframe cube like you are and then you
just draw like a black Cube like fully
filled in Cube that's a tiny bit smaller
so you can see the outlines but the rest
of it's filled in no that actually might
look worse because you can see the
difference in size cuz it's 3D I don't
know there's got to be some easy way to
just have the edges like colored but
yeah you could get away with stuff like
that in 2D so I never
I don't know you lose a lot of the
um I think if we zoom in that's
good you lose like a lot of the benefit
of 3D from having it fully toed down I
mean but that's the most that's the way
it's most playable I mean gam play is
the most important thing
because like I think um the original
devs prioritize it looking cool too much
yeah that that actually looks kind of
weird I'm not a fan of that actually
well this is the
fov yeah okay yeah if we change fov it
might be
better what's the fov at it was at
before like I wonder how good we can
make it and
just oh just zoom out a bit more I
[Music]
guess the funny thing is I can literally
put it on a
tab the uh the
camera a tab yeah you just press tab
switch camera
mode oh right if you want to do that so
you could go in isometric or whatever as
I don't think it's playable in isometric
right it's not for that I think it's
cool to watch it is
symmetric I personally don't think so
but I'm fine with it as an option if
other people do because I just wouldn't
use it but if other people want it
whatever but as long as it's not the
default I think if you were watching a
whole bunch it makes sense because then
you can see a whole bunch like you're
saying but other than that
Holy it's like okay so like these things
are shooting the angle off B isn't it of
oh wait shoot
yeah a little
bit but it's like it's off by a small
fixed amount isn't it it looks weird to
see the uh pickups as cubes I think
they're like they they fashion them like
Holograms in the original
game so they don't have they're kind of
more like Holograms I think if you just
draw draw a a cube without yeah it
doesn't have to be
yeah exactly all I was doing was getting
the stuff into 3D likeit obviously until
we yeah I get it um can we fix these
like CU these angles are really weird
that like not aiming in the direction
that you're actually aiming is really it
throws you off a bunch right yeah and
also not having the guide be like two
inches is not
helpful I I made the guide longer but
okay I know it's weird 3D is just a
whole different piece man I guess well
how is it it keep there's something
weird
here get weapon
aim oh you know what it is hang
on yeah yeah yeah hang on I think I
know yes
okay yeah it's just literally that I
wasn't using it y yeah that would do it
why does that
work see if you can figure out why it's
offset a little bit fix
this I'm almost done with my thing and
then I'll be able to oh you're coding in
the
back yeah I'm using some box 2D like
code and it works for them and not for
me I'm not sure why
one there you
go that's now the longer ones I think I
actually made it too long now yeah this
is ridiculous it'll make this half the
L it is going where I
click but uh it's not
going yeah cuz that's not rendering at
all that's just like the game logic
which shouldn't be changed yeah but the
angle just off by a little bit mhm
I mess
up mess something up
well this is just them all having sniper
as
well yeah see how it's kind of like
going through walls it looks weird when
it doesn't work correctly yeah almost
just haven't fixed it yet no no no I'm
just seeing like you see why I did it in
the first place yeah no of
course that's normal
I'd love I'd love to have this thing in
uh the correct angle that would be
great is the angle that the box is at
the same
get
angle well isn't that just math a0 2
hang on
can't we just replace all this B2
[ __ ] with like l t equals
A2 well so the B2 rot isn't just a float
it has like two floats in it or
something yeah but then you did get
angle of that yeah you get a angle in
radians and you can do whatever with
that yeah it's still offset yeah it's
all
as though you see I literally just
replace it with
at2 this right close negative sign sign
cosine you don't have an ad
blocker you're just advertising cruises
on stream
oh uh they keep they keep breaking the
damn ad blocker Google keeps breaking
the damn things
why is there is there not like a just a
c reference dock site that isn't like
all these garbage
ones I don't
y I don't know what changed then
actually with these two things they
should be the same
it's not off by like 90 degrees or
anything
either I assume that
um
right oh hang on what's last aim Y what
are these
things oh that's where the Drone
actually
aimed but like when you say it's wear it
aimed
like how is that that's the direction
that's the like the the normalized
vector in which it it is the normalized
a vector okay so it should be that you
take this
Vector
um oh then I don't have to do any of
this stuff if if if you have that as a I
didn't realize this is a vector okay so
can I just do plus last a
y maybe yeah I think that we've
massively I've massively
um over complicated it
yeah it's but we have to play with the
rotation matrices for a
bit isn't it literally just plus aim God
width times uh drone
this yeah okay I need to get some coffee
or something because I'm being stupid
today and coffe is going to solve that
usually
does usually does
that's cool
that does it work now yeah
nice wait so if you aim at I guess it
won't work with the camera Pro normally
so in 2D you could put your mouse like
on something and if you weren't moving
it would like aim exactly to that exact
spot where your mouse is but I think
with the perspective that'd be tricky no
it wouldn't you could hit you just a
it's just a ray cast
so what you do you R cast the mouse
position right to the world Point okay
and then that's the target position and
you're done
yeah we might I wonder if we have to do
differently now CU yeah try hitting like
the corner of a wall or something very
specific and see if it actually
hits well they kind of don't let me
you can turn them off it might be easier
just in demo like uh it's pretty ACC
because I think it's pretty accurate
because it's top down
still yeah well it was accurate in full
top down before yeah it's pretty
good but I mean it's in 3D you're going
to just want a r cast anyways I'm
sure I mean you you mainly control it
with this deck anyways which I did order
a
controller yeah did you figure out what
one or what the controller was that you
liked or whatever nope I just bought up
slightly better than basic controller
good reviews lost 200 bucks oh you did
buy one yeah nice I just got
I thought I got rid of stuff that wasn't
being
used
oh this one is not being
used okay there you
go I think next will be
the oh these aimu still don't look good
is the problem
yeah the cylinders just look kind of
strange to
me I don't know be I don't I think this
was the worst looking part of the
original as
well the like mine or yeah the aim
guides in I oh okay I thought they look
fine in like theirs
especially you don't think so like I
have to play it more to see I thought
they look fine in retrograde Arena
I love the accelerator man it gets so
fun especially if if you burst shot that
weapon so it starts off the bat like
bouncing like crazy everywhere the
projectile bounces are the coolest thing
honestly no I know that's why you're
saying like yeah if we eliminated
bouncing it'd be faster I mean sure know
but like I see it now right yeah it'd be
a lot less fun yeah part part of the
appeal of the game on to me is like the
chaoticness because you can there is a a
definite skill component of the game but
a certain point sometimes things just
ain't going to go your way and there's
only so much you can do about
it oh I was like what were they doing
they were charging guess you can't see a
charge
met we add that back in
expion yeah you should definitely try
and at the very least make it
transparent because right now it just
like covers everything I think it is
that be easy fix I don't it it covers
everything if so I some I think it was
supposed to be but something is wrong
yeah so this blend additive
perhaps well that's only if you're
bursting bursting it doesn't do the
blund additive right so what's this then
it's just explosion color and fall off
color it is
faded that's weird like does that like
not work in 3D then should no it
definitely should that's what I use but
you can't
see you can't see anything through them
though so there's something weird yeah
3D is just annoying
man yeah I don't know why you can't see
anything through them okay that's weird
let's see I wonder if if that
is is there like calling or something
there shouldn't be well no I I know um
Spencer explicitly enabled like the
alpha something and his Tower climb code
and I I'm pretty sure I read that was
the default in 2D but maybe it's not in
3D maybe in 3D it doesn't blend it
doesn't take Alpha to account because if
you look in Tower climb he does like an
explicit Alpha thing and I was wondering
why he did that cuz I thought that was
implicitly the default so he was just I
thought he was just kind of explicitly
saying use the default but potentially
he was on to
something well he definitely was because
his works but where was yeah and his
looks really good right yeah
um I don't know just search Alpha in all
caps
Alpha it is begin blend mode blend Alpha
yeah I remember seeing that because I
thought that was
strange do a
burst uh burst is a different code
though I think yeah burst
Cod well if you try on burst it'd be
easy to test it's still like culling
stuff from the
background it's like stopping rendering
because it it like pops back into
existence it's
weird oh it's harder to see on the
stream it looked to me like it was just
covering it but if it's calling it
that's very
strange we're uh trying to make it so
that we can have like Alpha transparency
in 3D
uh on the explosions it doesn't seem to
be working I don't know what would be
different about them that's a good
yeah I we should even need to deal with
this should we
H there's already transparency on it
isn't
yeah can have Cube wires or cube solid
this is a sphere solid a sphere with
Alpha is what we were trying to do it
works on the um doesn't work if we look
at the cubes do these look
right they do right CU it like it abs
cubes oh hang on is
it
fade explosion
color does fade fade to Alpha or does It
Fade to
Black
um it fades to be clear I think zero
Alpha is just clear transparent and then
like one alpha or 255 whatever just like
yeah the cubes are fine Spencer we're
trying to get the explosions for
whatever reason you can't see anything
behind
them mess with alha on color
yeah let me try
something
um that might be it yep that was it very
stupid
what I might have just figured out this
works my problems for the last couple of
minutes
yeah the explosions literally just take
a chunk out of
everything that's so strange yeah I see
yeah yeah see it just takes a chunk out
of
that
okay here's
end
why let's see
because there's not actually a depth
component apparently it's just um based
on draw order
maybe so if you want to make it easier
you could all those look explod a
second or they're just not
exploding not getting explosion
yeah cuz the you picked up the flat
Cannon
it and now you have the imploder yeah it
didn't do anything see
[Music]
that I think that worked though no but
there was a
couple there was a uh a couple weapons
that should have exploded and caused an
explosion and didn't I might have messed
up the color
I
mean yeah that look because it's
actually working here it's like I can
see the it's not like cutting out the
well no but that's the burst remember
you did the burst
differently let's see maybe I just mod
Bend
Alpha on don't you do that though no
somewhere else here I
goes I can't oh yep yeah that's better
that's better right they look huge but
better so we got to fix the explosion
still but at least
it's
so and what did you do you did two
things you did two spheres for the fall
off I guess you
said yeah well the way I did it was two
Circle again it's it's a lot easier to
do stuff in 2D cuz you can just overlay
things so yeah I had like one ccle
overlay
things yeah I think it gets a little
weird though from what I've seen you do
but
it is the radius wrong hang on maybe the
radius is
wrong bunch of spars here why are there
four sphere why are there four circles
for the explosion radius of
burst okay so um there's probably an
easier way to do it but I was blending
some of the normal explosion color with
the color of the Drone to make it
slightly colored um like if the Drone
bursts you can kind of see the color of
the Drone and explosion but not totally
so it doesn't like overwhelm stuff just
so you can visually tell like who
bursted but probably don't want to
exactly rep like create four spheres in
I don't know how you want to do it but
probably not
that I think we take these two out and
then we so this will just be a full
color initially and then we will we'll
just blurp the color CU it's overlaying
something is the radius the radiuses are
too big
right um the burst radius well no they I
don't know are the explosion radiuses
wrong I mean just see if you get coton
them because it should be pretty much
Pixel
Perfect like in in my original version
if you're in the explosion at all you're
going to be
affected
MH maybe not much but
some is that how do their explosion
animations as well as like a
circle yeah no uh well again I thought
it was a lot simpler so on switch it's
it's just a circle but on Steam I have
to play more with the steam version it's
so again it looks better but it's less
clear where the explosion is they have
some smoke kind of a circle but it's
like randomized but it's not super clear
if you're in the explosion or not so I'd
kind of like some kind of blend of maybe
like some smoke effect would be cool but
I want you to know exactly somehow where
the explosion radius is because making
things less clear for the sake of making
them look cool is just bad game sign in
my opinion yeah if you can make it look
cool and you know it's it's usable it's
playable like that's awesome but you
can't sacrifice playability for cool
graphics yeah the first Gamers will do
is turn all the graphics off down to
minimum
anyways some Gamers depends if they're
super competitive whatever yeah but a
lot of people just crank them up and
it's they yeah it depends on person but
yeah I know what you
mean I don't know why you can't just use
the color of the Drone for the burst
explosion well if it was the exact color
then the Drone would get lost in a burst
then it make it seem like just one giant
because it's the all the same color so I
need to make it
littleit yeah so I have it now does it
look okay yeah it looks fine I mean we
can we can tweak it later but looks fine
for now burst
fine yeah the explosions in general
could
definitely um like use some kind of
effect I don't know what but this
later he wanted these pickups to be
uh hang
on so in the original a cube not wire
right well no the way they had it it was
like a floating Square so see if you can
can do
that um like maybe if you make the Y AIS
zero that could work because it still
be yeah
or maybe like what happens if you make
it zero like why is
zero uh it's on the
ground oh That's How high oh oh make no
no no okay so make the thickness of it
zero so instead of Y being pick up
thickness make y pick a be yeah
thickness be zero or like if that
doesn't look right then like 0.1 or
something because they theirs is
basically like a floating
hologram if you don't know what I mean
just look up a picture of uh retrograde
Arena it'll make
sense see they had something under it so
you could kind of tell but yeah just
just look so yeah just it's hard to
explain just look up a picture quick you
don't even have to play the whole game
but so it was like semi-transparent they
had an icon on it and then they had like
a circle underneath so
technically the um hit box of their
pickups were actually circles not um
squares but uh yeah there was there's
yeah zoom in on
it oh it's just on the steam store here
yeah so it's just
a it is a
wire yeah it's it's like a wire with the
floating like like something the circle
thing under I don't think you we can do
that we can get that to
oops so yeah it is a wire but it's not a
cube it's like a you know what I mean by
floating hogr though right kind of
thing that's the that's at least the
closest I
looked um
3D rectangle in
3D maybe I can do zero
on
it might still work I think it would I
we'll see yeah it
works yeah it doesn't look good but
we'll fix that
yeah so we'll do like
this yeah we need to get some good icons
at some point oh yeah
but honestly might have to I don't know
I haven't really I've looked at icons I
can't find any pre-made icons that I
like because most of them are like we
can get some St commissioned if we uh
are going to actually make it look good
yeah that might be best because some of
the the um pack like icon packs are
either just like normal like AR-15s and
Pistol like 1911 pistols like real life
weapons which don't work or just like
generic sci-fi guns which don't really
tell you how the weapons are
differentiated
there we
go now the text is still off
two have to figure out the text
alignment and
stuff yeah as long as up it's fine for
now we do have the Holograms
mhm trying to see what else we want to
mess with right now
of
energy oh yeah you don't have the energy
meter yet that's it's going to be tricky
to figure out how to make that look good
I
think let's look at the main I mean the
main thing is the the way the cubes are
done in impulse Wars
right yeah that's a big component so
let's see how they have this they
have so their cubes are actually maybe I
just Boot It Up
so yeah it's they're they're kind of
wire but they're not seethrough you can
just see the outlines like edges of
them I think that is
black yeah let's see what's nice too if
you use true black as the background
then it just looks really clean and OLED
monitor which I have which is why I I
like the black background
yeah so you can't see the back of the
cube is the thing yeah that's what I'm
saying they're not wireframe they're
like solid but you can see the
edges like the edge
lines well hold on you can
see you can see through them this
way oh underneath yeah that's we don't
need to go that deep yeah they they went
all out in these effects
we don't need to go that crazy in my
opinion no I think what it is actually
you can't you can't see you can see
through them can't
you uh actually kind of only from like
the bottom not from the top or only from
the sides not from the top I think they
just put a they just put on the top they
just put um
squares yeah they might have I think the
the top is just like you can't you can't
see through the top but you can see
through the side huh you could just
render another Cube that has zero y AIS
so like zero height and put it on
top so it' be two cubes per wall which
is like not a big
deal they have the we need that the uh
what it
this Bloomer whatever on the projectile
for sure yeah and I I do like the little
particle effects when they hit those
those that's not as um essential but is
kind of
cool I I need to play I
need something that simple though yeah
that's like incredibly freaking simple
yeah no I agree um but I I do need to
play more of the steam game because I do
remember I played a little bit um I do
remember thinking if you turn it up to
altro settings all like some of the
effects is just too much it's just too
busy so I'll have to figure out like
what we want and what we don't want cuz
yeah if you turn up to Max they kind of
just threw everything out at it and it's
it's you can't really tell what's going
on honestly this line is
tricky yeah see I don't think I don't
think that's a cylinder this line yeah
no no I mean not this one yeah this
could very well be screen space it yeah
but this is it's kind of like an
outlined interesting oh you talking
about the little grid that follows you
no this so this line where my Crosshair
is yeah the aim guide no
oh oh yeah yeah the the thing around the
wall that's kind of hard because that's
not that doesn't wrap all the way around
the cubes you can see yeah it's just the
inside yeah so you have to have the
inside
Area I mean or the it's also the outside
it looks like but oh yeah it is it
doesn't go through
yeah so the walls are like partially
seethrough but not I don't know it's
weird are see- through here wait I think
the inside part of the walls are
see-through but not the outside see that
you can can you not see through here no
no no look go go up go up more or down
it doesn't matter uhhuh um and go to the
right so where that like where it Curves
in makes a little like U up top see how
you can't see through the wall on that
side there's nothing to what would you
see there oh yeah you can't see this
there would be a line there yeah so the
the inside of you don't we don't have to
do all this though this is just what
they did
to it's like very difficult to get these
types of effects right I like this kind
of this it's funny how they have this
grid that follows
you yeah that is interesting I don't
really know if we need it but it's kind
of
[Music]
cool it was interesting though I played
around with just rendering the grade in
2D and it it made it really busy not
really busy but Spencer didn't really
care for it and I kind of agreed I liked
it better without it but it works in
this game but I didn't really like it
when I did it's underneath you as well
yeah it's interesting actually that it's
it's not one Cube you know the outside
it's four cubes mhm I see that going
down yeah and hang on is
it these cubes no it's two no it's three
I think I think it's two actual cubes
with like the little line
detail I guess or is the line detail
just in the middle of one
definitely so they actually do use use
the
3D a bit more I don't think we're going
to make our game look better but we
could make it look better than is now I
don't think we're going to make it look
better than retrograde Arena because
they clearly spent a lot of time on
this like the Drone has a little like
glossy effect on it that shouldn't be
too hard with like materials or whatever
but I don't know if we need that
honestly
[Music]
cleaner well I we the thing is we would
need to know which tiles are part of the
wall unless they don't go all the way oh
wait did they go all the way down hang
on I think they don't the floating cubes
are
different oh so everything everything
that's fixed is that height though oh I
can do this this will be super easy and
this will look
cool
okay yeah yeah yeah so we're they're not
they're not
cubes they're not uh they pillars
yeah so a draw
cube is this called on everything or
including yeah okay here's
floating okay perfect so
wait
four oh they are 4x4
on is it doing anything
I think so
oh yeah this is it is but it's not this
is still not how it is in the game in
the original game I'm pretty sure what
do you
change oh wait this
is whoa why is the floating wall like
going into the wall yeah yeah yeah
yeah but they're they are still cubes
mhm so I guess it's got to be like
this and then we have to make these
things they're not actually transparent
I don't think at least not from the top
no I don't think the cubes are
transparent at
all mhm
so what if we make none of these
transparent to start
here
yeah so then this is going to be not
fade what's like
there that looks totally different
immediately oh yeah
it's a step in the right direction I
think it's not getting the lines at the
top but I think that is a render like I
think that's because it's like the one
pixel or whatever yeah that's weird well
it's weird how it shows up on some of
them but like the tops but not all the
tops uh yeah I guess that's true
yeah I yeah the collisions the cubes are
in they're uh I this that's the physics
I think well no um the floating walls
are smaller than walls so you you need
to render them smaller oh what are
what's their size uh there's some
constant how do we know what that
is uh my original
code um whenever I render a wall I check
if it's floating and then I get the
thickness based off
that I see angle here oh it's the extent
the wall extent is already set up see
where I do that um in width and height
all
extent yeah so that'll have what you
need that's right there is a constant
but I just set it in there
does not like
St what doesn't it like wall extent yeah
like why doesn't it like it I
mean I don't know let's
see the other big question is how we get
like thicker wireframes
it's like I'm almost tempted to pipe
these crazy stupid things to like pipe
rep
error into what can I just
do yeah literally I do that works
that's
funny wall extent dox I
guess
yeah yeah yeah extent have X and
Y but in this case they're the same but
I just kept it like that because I could
change it in the future I don't
signals and you got to figure out what's
why that's happening that's that I would
oh yeah this
is yeah this oh you made them all the
floating wall size that's that's it is
that what happened I think so I did wall
extent oh
really they the extent should
be different if they're floating or
not is this the radius
curved well did you have multiplied by
two so it
is oh that's just like yeah yeah the
half distance is what I mean not radius
yeah yeah yeah well that's what an
extent is I forgot about
that oh
lovely that's like a yeah that's like a
physics thing I guess yeah yeah I
learned about that with box extent is
like okay width or something well that's
something yeah there we go now the
floating walls look smaller and if yeah
now see they're colliding accurately
well more accurately because you're not
rotating them but good progress they're
not
rotated yeah they they rotate they can
but you're not ring them
rotating
angle yeah you're probably to calculate
angles because I just draw rectangle Pro
passing the
angle
but this does not have a rotate yeah I
know it's
annoying okay rotate we'll probably have
to make a helper function just you hear
the
points um like yeah like draw rotated
Cube draw rotated whatever like that'd
be nice to have a little helper but for
now we'll just get it working
yeah there is a it's just you have to
figure out how this stuff
works to do
this like what is rotating relative
oh that does
it I think I did I think it works whoa
no it does not
they're around the origin instead of
around the
center that's kind of
funny yeah it looks funny uh I think
I've had that happen before in 2D too
can you imagine if everything just moved
like that be mind bending
you could totally make a game this
like yeah things are
orbiting that does not help
I think now you have to do you draw it
at
yeah um that's actually really freaking
easy see if you can Collide accurately
with them when they move though because
maybe it's like flip just to be sure it
looks
right looks like it uh well no it at
least from here it's I don't know the
collisions are
weird it's the 3D well it's like you're
going you were going into it before like
flipping into it and then at one point
on the other side of it you were like
slightly not touching it well I don't
know if I have the Drone models
perfectly yeah something is slightly I
think the rotation is pretty good
yeah what's like what's slightly off oh
yeah the projectiles just went through
it I think the rotation direction is
correct yeah I don't think it's that oh
wait hang on is it coll with the bullets
well oh that
looks that it
no the bullet was shifting on the
cube the mine was like shifting as it
was attached to the
cube oh yeah they stick to cubes or no
wait I missed it it was moving around it
was moving around on the cube yeah that
shouldn't happen that's like a rendering
thing
yeah I mean they look like they're
rotated correctly they're just
not I'm trying something is look at the
accelerator bouncing it was like not it
was like bouncing right before it hit
the yeah like look at this yeah yeah
something it's not rotating in the wrong
direction though right
it looks like it's rotating in the right
direction I I don't know this
perspective is honestly just kind of
weird it's hard to see this I mean I can
like I can just shoot it on the right
side right and see that it
rotates yeah oh wait no it is it is
rotating in the wrong direction it looks
like hang let see so if I shoot it
here yeah it's rotating in the wrong
direction
totally okay
so what is it rotate
that it looks like it's bouncing off the
face correctly now doesn't
it um
yeah it's kind of hard for me to see
because your chair is covering it and
also like
the yeah it's hard to just see if it's
just going by in 3D
okay some of the projectiles bouncing
off the walls though they seem to bounce
off the walls like a little bit before
after like some of the collisions are oh
wait yeah but that's in everything isn't
it likeall too mm M see that up
okay did you turn Collision or
continuous collisions off I forget I
know we we're playing with that if you
turn it off that would make it weird
what was it continue with it should be
an M if you search an M it'll be
function
okay um and then go down to where create
the word yeah it should be fine yeah it
should be fine it's
fine yeah um okay I was pretty sure I
only modified that locally I was testing
with it but just to make I don't
remember fiddling with that like we
played with it for projectile
specifically for a bit yeah I I did L
glue but I couldn't remember if you did
as well so just I played with
projectiles I
remember I think this the physics are
fine I don't think it's a physics I
think it's the rendering okay
so here the
current it looks way better now though
with the cubes being the right size and
they're like they're actually floating
at a different height now as
well oh okay it's kind of hard to tell
but yeah uh you would be able to tell if
I rotated the freaking
scene yeah yeah right which maybe we
should do for the purpose of figuring
out if it's actually rendering where we
want it
to
yeah I'll just put at a slight angle
uh like even if I just do like what's it
like well this will be somewhat of an
angle it's still in
perspective that's actually not going
slight angle but
oh they don't look like cubes now they
look like slices don't they
oh that is so weird to look at at that
angle okay so there yeah there is
something still screwy here then yeah
hang on
is the extent
four uh for normal walls it should be
yeah the extent is
for
um yeah for well um I guess
who well that's what I'm
asking yeah go look and create walls and
game or I can look quick I'm I'm like
there create wall is the pillar
version yeah there you
goly
now that looks
better where do I do that is it in here
wall thickness wall thickness is
four
waitting wall thickness okay so the wall
thickness is four and the floating wall
thickness is three it's the
extent um looking yeah it's half of that
so it's one and a half for floating
walls and two for walls is the extent so
yeah if you multiply by two that should
be actual size which is what you're
doing so it's one so it is one and a
half okay so if it's
floating then it's
1.5 I guess to you could just do you
could just not you could just set the Y
star to be um dependent on the extent
because then you wouldn't have to have a
conditional it's
centered I guesser yeah it is centered
okay now you want to do something
different for the never mind I guess you
want to do something different for the m
w
equals negative uh
wall extent. y
I do
this but the problem is that you made
the no I can't do
yeah this gives you slices it's the
thing so I I mean it looks to me like
these if these are
cubes there probably
there that does
it why they look like they're floating
so
high that is
weird but they now they look like
they're floating really high doesn't it
yeah it does even though they should be
lower
control all right I'll be back in a
minute I'm G to get some more
water they look above it's weird
I think the iso camera would help but it
we wouldn't be able to aim it so
I this is
something ra grid
line oh this render empty cell actually
we have it right here
I don't even know if this does anything
huh
okay whatever we'll just do
this and this is under below mode 3D as
well hang on maybe this was good it was
just in the wrong
s t
that's
weird whoa what is what is the
spiral it's a bug is what it is oh what
are you work you're working on the uh I
wanted to see if we could put a grid
underneath it now because in 3D it might
look very
different
oh
um could they just be
2D no no yeah it still has 3 everything
yeah yeah I'm just thinking they almost
seem like 2D but they're flat guess yeah
they they uh they change with
perspective and
everything I mean it's going to be cool
because you'll literally just be able to
attach a camera to a drone for instance
and then you'll be able to get like the
same sort of perspective as the as
retrograde
sorry if you said something to me in the
last like couple seconds I missed it
good I
was these freaking PS man I want to be
in and out of my office like every two
seconds
how do I mess this up so
bad what's what's wrong with
this oh dummy okay what
four well can't you just render a bunch
of cubes and make their height zero
yeah you can it will look
worse will it yeah why because uh you'll
get
like the borders will get messed up with
floating
point oh yeah so you got to draw 3D
lines
instead it's even it's more efficient
anyways okay yeah I guess that's
true when it comes to C like rendering I
don't
know I don't know yeah I don't I don't
can't think of
anything very basic I guess
so
yeah a lot of the really easy stuff I've
never done before so it's not common
sense to
me somebody please tell me what the heck
is wrong with this cuz this is drawing
crazy
things this honestly might be a good
like llm question because this is like
I'm sure it's seen tons of grid drawing
code well so have I I'm just [ __ ] it
up I'd rather debug it than have to deal
with it freaking llm debugging it
see this is literally the llm broket
right
here that's the reason I'm having
trouble the freaking llm
bro I don't know what it thinks it's
doing
but yeah when it when there's simple
things like this I can't figure out
within a few minutes I know I could
figure it out it just take me longer I
sometimes just try asking LM and if it
you know I might have to tweak a little
bit but it's usually easier but it
usually cost me more time every single
time I like try to crush an llm it's
like [ __ ] takes me more
time it's it's I've actually gotten some
good results with rendering because I
think I am so ignorant in that yeah but
that's the thing right it's like it's
only good cuz you're crap at it like I
do the same thing with math and then
half the time it gives me stupid
suggestions where it's like literally
like if I just thought about it and like
tried to figured stuff out it would have
been better in less time and I would
have learned
more I mean in my understanding is you
can't really rely on lmm for math so oh
no they say that they're superum at math
and math will be the first domain to
follow to
llms uh really who's saying that H scam
mman every everything I've seen and
heard is complete opposite they suck at
math no they have the big it's the the
math benchmark where they have the
hardest math questions that like nobody
can solve but the LM solve them it's
no hey yeah didn't you know all the code
is gonna be written by AI it's like so
scam it's like so sad as well cuz like
these companies have awesome devs
working lot and the CEOs just lie and
lie and lie and lie
yeah my
grid hang on G
gone man this is this is annoying
actually
here just do
so
almost except I think it goes
interesting that actually is kind of
cool though no wait it it's oh yeah no I
kind of like
it's still like going
through the heck is wrong with these Y
coordinates CU render
wall what's the height I do negative 8
at the
start8 should be
correct we really need this thing to be
in like some sort of perspective where
we can actually see what's going
on cuz like I can't tell what's
happening honestly the easiest way to do
it is
just like isce is really easy for
debugging because you can actually
see oh yeah I mean for debuging that's
that's
cool what I do I just was curious how it
would look top
down it'll probably look better stop
down eventually but we not until we get
it
working yeah like look at this isn't
this yeah this grid is totally
at it's in the middle of the cube
that's kind of what we want though at
least it goes on the floor yeah yeah
yeah in the original game it's on the
floor I honestly kind of like the way it
looks now really I think you're going to
lose the dep from it if you do
it well because if you look at the
original it it it might be so you know
where those like glowing lines are in
the in the I don't know bottom middle of
some oh yeah that's that's a
zero yeah but it almost looks like the
glowing wall is in the middle of the
wall cubes it is yeah so what you're
doing now is kind of correct I think
well but there's also there's a grid
that's at the
bottom oh right the grid is below
everything yeah
I see but I can't figure out
why so why start
here this is bizarre to me I can't
figure out
why it looks like the wall should be
from8 to
8 but when I do it here I mean I can do
-6
it's kind of weird
though so we'll have to figure out some
coordinates but if we just want to see
if something looks
I think you do get more
depth when you see
this you still can't quite see the walls
the way they are the the the floating
walls don't look like the floating ones
are maybe the floating ones are just too
high they look too high to
me um something I think is scur with the
way that these coordinates are because
the floating walls are too high for
sure maybe that's all it is maybe it's
just that these pickups and floating
walls and the Bots everything is too
high yeah that might be it yeah look
it's totally too high okay so something
is just not working the way we think it
is with the coordinate system because
this ne6 should not line up also
something's not working because I keep
seeing drones like phase it look like
they phase into walls which is
strange I I I don't know why that is I
mean I have this y start y end
here
what if I don't do this does it just
screw everything
up
whoa
yep what the what what what what's
happening Matrix po Matrix okay
it's like it's drawing from zero up or
something it's weird no it's not drawing
from zero up drawing from
negative I think it's just that the
drones are too high up and like
everything is too high up but like
they're at
let me fix the
um the puffer colors
this is
24 that you have it and
then color
guess the map is oh the map changes size
that's
this is nice this is like a really
subtle
do let's do
this find 3
oh that's weird look it sticks up
doesn't it
odd I guess it's got to be some way with
uh something to do with how we're
drawing everything else
then
wait so you translate to
plus I need to translate this as well I
don't think so
this is actually isn't this
it or
no because if I go over
here some of these are still like this
is still way too high
right is it inconsistent
they oh no that cube is still totally
wrong should not be up there
awkward they're supposed to be at 0.5
they're supposed to be like basically on
the
bit don't work out went but
whatever oh shoot sorry I I have been
muted this whole time I didn't
realize I was saying stuff to you but I
didn't realize you could the whole time
I'm just ignoring the [ __ ] out of you
no it's
yeah I should have realized too because
my microphone has like its own toggle
which I usually use that's why it
doesn't show in Discord and it lights up
red when it's muted but I was ignoring
it should be very obvious but no worries
I've done that too but um you solved a
map
absolutely oh yeah I want to see that
yeah C we got to figure out this
rendered [ __ ] thing um I don't know
what's wrong with I think it's just
rendering stuff on top regardless of 3D
h on disc
sure let's
see hey
what doing rendering
Shenanigans I was gonna say it looks a
lot better yeah there's still some major
RoR render bugs so as soon as those go
away it'll be actually pretty cool how
did you solve the the the double line
thing where you have multiple boxes on
top of each other like on the
borders uh we drew it solid oh okay that
that makes sense it's just it's solid it
like it's faded but it doesn't have the
transparency so
yeah okay let me uh let me show let me
pull up the E the bottom
honestly and then share my
screen hopefully wellon my my Mac won't
explode trying to run it
and all right so they disappear once
they hit their goal let me see watch
this wait where why does this not can't
why can I not watch watch
stream there
so the green is gold
oh can they just turn on a dime yeah at
the moment they just turn on a dime
right yeah I mean there's no like
momentum in here yeah look at
that they just snap to the goal that's
so funny yeah so apparently I'm an idiot
and uh you can't find something if you
only tell its relative distance as one
as one point you have to give it X and Y
relative yes yeah makes
sense I was trying to rely on you know
the neural network to just be like yeah
I can just figure 2D space out with one
dimension well technically you kind of
can but like it's like hot you're
playing hot and
cold yeah I mean it went from not being
able to figure it out reliably for all
the agents to at least for this map as
100% successory now it's kind of funny
how you have like these like Snap terms
in continuous space yeah it is weird
actually want to see like well you see
here's the thing that's a little bit
weird from that right so the action
space is uh discrete and it's split into
like acceleration is4 to4 as just like a
raw value and then steering is negative
pi to Pi um with 13 values on a
circle so it's mostly going forward and
then just snap turns it's fun right
like how it gets to like being um that's
funny like a smoother turn would mean
that what that's going to have to do is
because it's making each of these steps
like each of these are like happening at
each frame in terms of the physics
right that cool
so whoa in order for it to make it like
a smooth turn it would have to do like
change the steering for just one step
and then put it back to straight
repeatedly yeah
it's probably just yeah instead of that
right now it's just it's going to like
the exact degree it needs to go and then
and then returning to
straight because as you know if you do
if you're holding a turn for more than
two or three frames you make a
circle
yeah cool they need to now uh well
there's the momentum thing
obviously uh so that's what I was
wondering because in in in the GPU Drive
implementation I didn't see anything
about like this at
all I mean maybe it's in Madrona but um
I'd be pretty surprised if this is how
they have it implemented that' be kind
of
hilarious I think I think theirs just
don't like kind
of run around in these directions
because they have uh penalties for
leaving
Lanes so they can turn on a
dime well I think I think if you get the
actions to go like I said earlier where
you just have like you you turn for one
step and then go back the next step and
that's like okay then you create like a
smooth effect but but you know that's
what I was wondering is like why can't I
just make the whole thing
continuous um besides problem being hard
well you can but the thing is you still
have driving is it's like the
amount it's like the steering is not the
direction that I face it is the amount
it's the delta that I give to the angle
that I'm taking
right so it's like a hard steer turns
you more quickly but it's still going to
take many frames to
turn right so so messing with that time
step is what I wasn't certain kind of
how I should handle that yet it's like
how do I do I apply it at
every you know do I apply it at every
single frame or do I apply it at you
know it is probably like every frame
right it's you look at the steering like
the steering strength yeah that's that's
what's happening right now well except
then the amount that they can turn in
one frame is like massive it looks yeah
they can turn like a massive amount per
frame because it's literally just snap
steering let's see move Dynamics what's
happening here it's doing like 90 degree
turns in one frame
yeah so it's
steering it's based off of heading and
this is stuff that I wasn't like fully
confident in
but okay steering is its raw value from
negative pi to Pi so it's multiplying
that by the speed times
the the Delta
time well I mean it's it's doing it I
think I mean it's times .5 times
acceleration squared or
whatever. five
radians 0 five like 0.5 when you
multiply times acceleration V * t plus
.5 time a squ but the the rotation
is there's probably something in GPU
drive for that would there probably
something I didn't do exactly correctly
here I mean this is just to get it going
right well I mean I guess there's also
the Collision checks are going to be the
more and and so what is interesting
though is like this map really only
learns
because one of them starts pretty close
to mhm the goal when I picked another
map where everything's pretty far from
the goal it it seemed like when I ran it
for a
while it just like wasn't able to find
it Well yeah it's hard because it's it
has to do it's like a 90 step Horizon
problem with no intermediate rewards
right yeah just no immediate rewards at
all it's only on the end goal so if if
you don't if you don't luckily hit it
you kind of learn nothing that entire
time frame well the good news is you're
going to be training over a bunch of
maps that are going to have easy and
hard tasks you know right right and then
it'll all help each
other
um yeah I think do really really really
dumb Collision checks and see how that
goes that's what I would say do next
Collision on everything or like like
between Lane Collision or um player
Collision or both yeah players
Lanes go off the like you can't go out
the road just
crashes all right I think yeah I'll have
to figure out how I'm going to go about
Lan Collision but I I'll think about it
well I I do the really stupid thing of
just looping over all the points or all
the segments
right yeah I guess just don't don't hit
at that point sure yeah
I mean there're little tiny line
segments in this data set specifically
right yeah they're tiny there's there's
10,000 of them okay point in box it's
Collision yeah I mean I was just going
to get like you mentioned just going to
create like a box around it and then if
you're within the Box well no now you
don't even have to do like the car is a
box right so if the Collision point is
in the box then you've
collided yeah no visually a box I just
haven't actually set it up to be a box
in terms of oh okay the car yeah the car
is not a box the actual car I haven't
like applied a length width to it but
like yeah yes you can do that yes okay
cool do that that should be that should
be like quick to code if it even if
it'll be quite slow to sim we'll see how
much that slows everything down um I
think it won't be that bad because if
you ignore the center lines that takes
out a lot of coordinates
yeah because you're really only looking
at looking at Road edges mhm or Lane
edges whatever
MH but anyways all right that's uh round
one
solid did
cool I'm GNA have
to work on this 3D renderer here so I
can go over there and see uh what we can
do there we can load a car model in and
stuff oh so I was I was gonna mention
this last night uh to Captain but um
something I think that could be fun that
I'm for sure gonna do on this
um en that could be interesting in yours
as well is I'm going to make a
firstperson mode and then open up a
window in the car so it looks like you
can actually see as if you're a driver
in it yeah Joseph mentioned that I think
it would be kind of I don't know like
nauseating maybe for impulse Wars
because like especially when you get hit
with like a sniper and you go flying
across the entire map you're like whoa
you know I mean we could try it but
honestly that's probably just like puka
mode yeah I mean there's a good chance
that it just like makes your brain
explode but it also could be cool so I
don't yeah we could try you know what's
wrong with this it's like sometimes they
look like they're too high and sometimes
they look like they're too low it's
crazy
um what's your Z are they all fixed well
they're supposed to actually be in about
the middle of the wall like there if the
wall is the Wall height is centered on
zero so it goes below and above and
these are supposed to be centered on
zero and small well the green one just
is just running through walls the green
one's just running through yeah it just
passed through walls like a second
ago yeah it's passing through walls so
you're you're where you're dropping
your your edge of your wall you're maybe
not take into account
uh that it's based on the center point
and not the edge it could be just that
yeah but I would have thought Captain
already did that for two days so I don't
know maybe it just needs to be
adjusted but then even like these green
ones like why do these green one these
green things look like
they're well they also look like they're
2D look they're missing a dimension well
they are planes but like they are
situated in 3D
oh but um but it looks like some are
high and some are low exactly and I
can't figure out why I can't tell if
it's just like draw order drawing them
on top even though they're technically
lower
draw order is a
thing I know maybe we should just add
like
a basic camera controls so we can like
pan this thing
around you can take if you look in the
GPU Drive stuff the camera controls I
addit are pretty
simple I think I make it where like you
can click and drag around and then the
scroll puts you through deeper in Z the
Scrolls a little awkward yeah in there
yeah
um just yeah go to the ocean no not that
one it it's it's it's its own enin
ocean um 90% of it's in the C file and
then you just have to in the dot set up
the camera yeah
because the do c is a where you actually
do
it um it's the at the top it's its own
function
this it's called like camera control or
something handle camera yeah
and I have that in my C but I don't know
how your rendering Works in impulse
it
camera yeah this is fine I think
andle and you just call this every frame
or whatever yeah I just call it every
frame um I think you got to put it in
the oh wait never mind you you you're
doing it reverse that's fine
like
oh like
50 yeah for mine I had to Target a car
because it's the GPU Drive spawn
locations are like negative 12,000 or
some ridiculous number so you just have
to know where your first thing you're
going to be looking at where the center
of your map is and then make sure you
pan it well
then what are the controls you click and
drag around to move and then use scroll
wheel to change the Z click and
drag so you should be able to like move
the
map
whoa It's like that might be a frame
thing yeah you should be use scroll
wheel to like adjust things and
then but it should be adjusting my mouse
as well like the events are not firing
correctly at
all it looks like the map also got
like can you rotate it or no you should
be able to yeah with what mine
rotates with what control
let me just pull that up okay so
clicking and dragging moves it laterally
um zooming messes with the like
scrolling messes with
z Oh I don't have rotate in here
now okay but rotating should be pretty
easy all you have to do is just apply
just change it with a button and to only
apply it towards I think the X degree or
no the x and
z I think if you do x and z uniformly I
think is what it should it's either x
and z or Y and Z or some combination of
two of the parameters and keeping the
other
fixed yeah this one is super glitchy for
uh on this like I have to fix quite a
bit I don't know why it would be glitchy
like is it just is there too many things
happening I think it's because the other
the bouse buttons are also being used
for yeah oh the mouse buttons are being
used yeah if
you like the wheel didn't even work
either like so something is
weird yeah I don't use the wheel that's
weird oh maybe you don't have a camera
Target maybe that's why it is
targeted no no no I have
a I have a parameter that says camera
Target yours is reversed yours that's
reversed but it's it's not like it's a
problem yeah no no no it doesn't make a
difference difference what I'm saying is
uh oh no you do have a Target where is
your your Target's
that what do we have
reversed I just meant like your while
loop is just permanently true I do wild
not window should close it doesn't
matter yeah I probably should have that
but it's yeah I I that actually does
matter yeah it makes it hard to close
with
escape and then I think I do all of my
destroys like in a separate function or
allocated yeah no that still is not
uh all right then I don't
know very
weird are you updating is it is it is
your is your camera forcibly updating
every step inside of the N logic
somewhere cuz mine I just only said it
one time at the create I didn't think
yeah I didn't think we were changing
it the camera's just static
um that's
weird so wait you said draw order is a
thing but
like it it affected me like
if how to how how to draw order affect
the blocks when Tower climb
um if you just draw like does it not
keep track of depth at all
or cuz like if it doesn't keep track of
depth and
how I'm trying to remember how it well
how it affected it because it made it it
was something was being was happening
weirdly when I was adding the
character on top of like the blocks and
doing my animations
mhm and I had to change how like things
were ordered let me try and if I can
read and remember like why I did
something hey I finally got black hole
stuff working like completely without
crashing stuff you guys want to see it
for a second
yeah oh you get a new weapon yeah um let
me share my
screen screen
yeah Smooth
video okay oh also a reference on it
took about 100 million steps to to beat
the first uh
level uh the on GPU Drive
yeah so the big like things are
obviously temporary you can you guys can
see this right yep okay yeah so it'll
like I still have to work out some of
the Kinks It'll like pull you into it I
don't I'm just doing this for like yeah
does something happen when you hit the
person or is it kind of just like it
starts to pull you in that direction so
basically anything in this like sphere
will pull you and its strength is based
on how close you are to it it's right
now it's linear but I might make it
something else you can just burst it
away or you could like break to stop it
pulling you as much actually break you
have to charge up to fire this thing
yeah because I don't want people just
spamming it yeah it'd be a little unfair
yeah and there's usually only like I
think like two shots but I'm just have
infinite right now cuz I'm testing
it but yeah you can use it to like move
floating walls or like move players it
has a weird interaction with the two of
them I guess they're like pulling each
other which kind of like almost cancels
them out it's weird oh interesting
they're like they themselves have their
own like physics logic yeah so every
everything's like pulled by
it you got caught in two of them
yeah here I'll turn it on so I can see
what it's like each
yeah so do box 2 do you make that really
simple yeah no I just apply like a force
so it's basically just and I I it's a
little more complicated because I want
it to be a little more accurate and
stuff but oh yeah I just drew the just
for um ease of use I just drew those
like big circles over everything because
all just doing it quick
so we start out with the black hole
weapon and have infinite ammo
but oh man I
suck I don't
know oh my I bursted a mine that killed
me yeah I don't know what I think it's a
cool idea what do you guys
think I'm trying to figure out if I
think the gravity pull you might only
like want to just have it like shoot two
of them or something like one or two and
then like the gravity effect would be
like a lot stronger I would think well
so like I said normally this weapon's
going to have an ammo of two yeah but I
just have it infinite for testing well I
mean if it only has two ammo like I
think the gravity effect could be maybe
like a shorter radius but much stronger
I don't know well it's already pretty
strong like I'm not fighting it there
but I was completely sucked in yeah I
might make the radius a little shorter
I'm not sure I do kind of want to type
of fall off as well yeah it's linear
right now but that's definitely not set
in
stone I'm just qu fall off and it's
really strong at the
center so wait quadratic would be it
drops off really fast when you get away
from the center yeah but very strong at
this that's how gravity works right
gravity is quadratic
okay um let me see about adding that
then
um yeah it's just here in scale right
now I just do like the scale affects the
magnitude it's just the distance divided
by the max the distance that is from the
like the affected enti I think if you
just squared what is it distance to make
it quadratic in this
case no well it has to be it has to be
normalized so it's between one and it's
zero and one um so it'd be
yeah
[Music]
like
blanking that's interesting that is how
gravity Works normally didn't know that
that is quadratic fall off or
whatever all right I got to head out
yeah all right see
you uh yeah it might actually this might
be rendering order stuff
now this is confusing I think it should
work like there's no way that they don't
have
depth in
here that wouldn't make
sense I know I'm getting kind of hungry
and uh I need to go get some food and
stuff before I'll probably be back uh
later today we gota like I gota get some
some stuff working on this I'd really
like to have like a nice render so we
can just get this stuff merged in and
start playing with
it I mean it's like it's it's just we
need to fix the bugs on it but like it's
already starting to look okay we
definitely need some effects and stuff
yeah yeah that's definitely looking a
lot better for
sure yeah yeah we
just the Collision stuff is obviously
like huge but I'm not I'm just not sure
you think that's like a rendering uh I
we should definitely figure out what the
heck is wrong with the rendering because
yeah it stuff is like it looks like it's
on the wrong height or drawn in the
wrong order or something I can't quite
tell
like am I going through walls here or is
it just hard to
see uh I don't think you're going
through a wall because if you you want
to really could just turn this off it
looks oh wait hang on have we it looks
like we're one tile off here right yeah
I see that I see that we could just be a
tile off are you going tile off in the
other side though is it like consistent
let's see see these these [ __ ] don't
kill me yeah look see I can't get
further than this yeah or TI off off by
one okay but are we off by one in the in
the bot
or yeah that's the
question
I I might it might be the walls because
I've seen projectiles look like they
phase through walls or I I've seen
things do other same behavior might be W
so then here this is what we have it's
wall pause.
X so pause. X well it could be this
translate stuff being
weird yeah okay so wait what do you I
missed this what do you need RL push
Matrix and pop Matrix for that's the
rotations uh
interesting oh you can just tell it to
oh that's kind of nice
I missed that that's cool yeah it's just
like hey your drawing rotated now oh I
like
that see you don't need a
rapper more you the more you
know I say which is kind of ironic RB is
a rapper but like stuff like text is
kind
of well sometimes rapper useful it's all
gone
that's interesting it is literally all
there is the grid just like screwing it
up doesn't make any sense the grid can't
be screwing up it's just
lines yeah
the walls are
gone and what did you
change I just took the translate
X yeah they they're just gone that's
bizarre
well this map kind of sucks for
testing too much
red um if you want there's one thing you
can edit I just exploded up
here I missed that look see a sof by one
still
right yeah and then if I go here wait if
you want to pin it to a map I can show
you how to do do that in like two
seconds
boom yeah we're off we're definitely off
by off by
one
yeah um so it was not the it was not the
Matrix
stuff two times
extent but is pause the center
point uh yeah pause is the oh so then
this is wrong isn't it
you were assuming it was something else
RL
translate this should be
minus wall extent
right
[Music]
um why are you subtracting the extent
because it's it's got to draw from left
you can't draw around the midpoint oh
right
yeah should wish you could I wish you
could just draw around the midpoint
that'd be
nice okay so now yeah all the positions
are centered at or all the positions
whatever
entity you might be having the same like
off like or yeah might need to do that
same change to everything I'm crazy off
now aren't
I now I'm no now I'm off by hang on I
was off by a half and now I'm off by
more than a
work I'm more off than I was
before now I'm actually off by one
two times wall
extent wall
extent is it the left
corner are we sure it's the middle it's
not the left corner of the
wall um
I I don't know I don't think you
actually have the drawn by the
midpoint well so I'm how I'm drawing
them I think I don't think they're
represented by the mid point no they are
they 100%
are why is this the pause the pause is
the midpoint because that's always how
box does
it now this this is too
much yeah but
then
correct
huh I just go
through guess we just go through these
no you you hit it it was just the height
was off the yellow
one yeah
still off you say it is the midpoint
then it should be
this I think it's justd it's 3D
rendering being weird I can tell you
with like a 99.9% certainty pause is the
midpoint nothing weird about
3D I'm just I don't
know you can have this exact same crap
in 2D it's the same it is virtually 2D
anyways because I'm just using a fixed y
I do remember I had to play a lot
with getting stuff to translate and it
was like different for different shapes
it wasn't like consistent which was like
frustrating so well this one is just a
radius right pause X the Drone no well
the the pause is always the actual
position in the world on the center of
the entity m
which is what we want so
yes the Drone render should be
fine
should but okay you're not inverting the
y axis is that like does that
matter it
could if you're doing it everywhere see
what's weird is if you're not if you're
not inverting the y- axis everywhere I
would think that you would be moving
inverted invertedly but you aren't right
I don't know you're controlling how
you're controlling it
but when you press W you go up
M okay that's
well it doesn't like the rendering
screwed up somehow yeah but like oh
actually I wonder if it
is no I think it is screwed up on both
man this is so close it's like you know
games look super dranky when stuff
doesn't quite line up and then it just
kind of all clicks
yeah because like imagine if this
actually lined up perfectly this would
be super smooth mhm
right it just like it's slightly
off I like this grid effect on the
bottom as well no I I do like that I
agree oh do you notice the grid actually
lines up now oh it does wait does it
wait no it's it's off in the center it's
off in the center but then it's
warped it
starts yeah now it's not even off by a
half okay something's Giga screwed well
it might depend on the map because
you're
drawing it's it's drawing around the
center yeah never mind I don't know
yeah yeah I'm not bouncing off the walls
as well when I uh I try to burst because
I'm not as close to them as I think
I still don't burst off the wall you
should if you get close
enough you can try against the blue wall
because that won't kill you yeah you
were just farther than you
thought yeah something's very
SC I'm trying to think it's like do the
projectiles look
right um
um they're off a little well they're off
in the same way I think you can see them
sometimes they I think they are the same
as the yeah they are yeah see this is
off by one as well cuz you go here mhm
yeah so this is it's off by one the
whole wall is off by
one well how the hell is that possible
like
how
plus hang on I haven't tried the other a
let me make sure it's the same on both
axes okay so this one is here and then
this
it's
like this one is hang
on okay so this one goes all the way to
the end right
whoa camera decided to start working
when I didn't want it
[Laughter]
to yeah no no it is okay it is off by
one on both axis though on the ax and
the Y yeah
so
how and this is absolutely how you would
do it
and you have the times two two * extent
is the
wiip with two times extent mhm yeah it
should be
right wait hang on you have with pause X
pause
y
origin yeah no the okay you off the
origin yeah so you
[Music]
do it's weird I couldn't tell you how it
works at this point no I mean it makes
sense it's just like somehow we have
somehow we are off by a
tile is like isn't it literally just
this one though but I tried this and it
didn't fix it I'm pretty sure
still off by a tile how did I just
change this and have it still be off by
a
something whenever you do figure this
out and get it fixed like you should
just at least like stage it or commit it
just yeah yeah I need to make a fork
like
fre
whatever but yeah I like to Stage
changes like even if I'm not ready to
commit like I think I mentioned that
before because I'm helpful if you
accidentally break something and can't
figure out what you broke yeah I'm
getting tired though I need to get some
food in me and I need to get ready to do
some stuff so
um for folks watching here more Dev
later today most likely uh if you want
to check out the project puffer doai
it's all open source new M being merged
in
soon Captain
here uh go ahead start the project help
St ton if you want want to get involved
with Dev join the
Discord if you want more RL content you
can follow me on X as well as checking
out the blog here